Finlandia ya tiene el sí de los 30
países de la otan y Suecia para cuándo
primero debe resolver sus disputas
Turquía se enfureció cuando en Suecia un
activista quemó el Corán frente a la
embajada turca el presidente erdogan no
quiere perder apoyos antes de las
elecciones de mayo además ankara acusa
estocolmo de ser indulgente con grupos a
los que Turquía considera terroristas
como los militantes kurdos
nuestras expectativas son claras Y
explícitas esperamos enmiendas legales
relativas a la lucha contra el
terrorismo y la lucha contra las
organizaciones terroristas que se
incluyen en el memorando de consenso
problemas diplomáticos que también tiene
que resolver con Hungría el gobierno de
Víctor orbán acusa a Suecia de burlarse
de la democracia húngara y de haber sido
protagonista en la paralización de los
fondos europeos para budapest
cuando los políticos finlandeses y
suecos cuestionan la naturaleza
democrática de nuestro sistema político
Es realmente inaceptable Así que
esperamos respeto ya sabes como
respetamos a todos los países
la otan sus miembros y especialmente
Finlandia consideran que necesitan a
Suecia mientras Finlandia es clave por
sus más de 1300 kilómetros de frontera
con Rusia la más larga de la otan y de
la Unión Europea Suecia aportaría la
alianza sus más de 7.600 kilómetros de
Costa
podemos dotar a la alianza de
profundidad estratégica y conectar los
países orientales de la otan con el
Atlántico geográficamente tenemos la
costa más larga del mar Báltico la isla
de cotland así como los importantes
puertos del mar del Norte con los
activos navales de Suecia sus recursos y
su fuerte posición en el aire hay un
sólido conocimiento de todo el mar
Báltico
Suecia ha hecho cambios constitucionales
para aprobar leyes antiterroristas más
estrictas espera n poder unirse antes de
la Cumbre de julio de la otan en bilnios
lituania y dejar junto a Finlandia
décadas como países no alineados